The following content is provided
under a Creative Commons license.
Your support will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
provide high-quality education for free.
To make a donation or to see more educational materials
from hundreds of courses, visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
Lecturer: Hello,
I am Sereni Devadas, a
lecturer in the School of Electrical Engineering and Computer Science
.
I will be lecturing alongside
Professor Eric Doman as an assistant professor in the Introduction to Logarithms 6.006 course.
Eric, say hello!
Eric Doman: Hello!
[Laughter]
Professor to the students: We hope you have a great
time in 6.006 learning about a
variety of logarithms.
What I want to do today is talk for a minute or so
about some administrative details, or perhaps even less.
I want to tell you that you should visit the
website linked above and read it. You will get
all the information
you need about the course from a comprehensive perspective:
the rules, what is expected of you, the problem table, the
exam schedule, etc.
I want to start right away and delve into important details
such as logarithms and the complexities of logarithms.
I want to take some time to give you an
overview of the course content.
After that, you will begin to delve into important details such as finding the largest value
in one and two dimensions
and talking about logarithms to solve
the problem of finding the largest value. You will see both forms and
you will find that there is a difference between the types These are the logarithms
that we will talk about in terms of detail and difficulty.
What I mean by that is that you
will get different processing times for these logarithms
based on the size of the inputs. We will determine the efficiency of these logarithms.
In that course, you learned about convergent complexity, and
the prerequisite for this course is course 6.042.
In that course, you learned about convergent complexity.
In this lecture, we will talk about analyzing simple, easy logarithms—
which logarithms are faster than others in
terms of convergent complexity.
You will be able to distinguish and know
which logarithms are faster than others,
assuming that you have large inputs, because they are less convergent in terms of complexity.
This is about efficient procedures.
Okay, let's start talking about this chapter.
When I say large inputs, I mean things
like the US highway system, a map
of all the highways in the United States of America. The
human genome, which has a billion letters
in the alphabet. Social network response on Facebook, I
think 500 million contracts or so.
Therefore, this is a large input.
Now we have a major definition that has really changed with the times. And so the
true definition of the 21st century
is, I think, a trillion dollars.
right? Back
when you were your age, it was as big as 1,000.
[Laughter]
I think my history dates back here. Back
when your Eric was your age, he was a million.
right?
[Laughter]
But what's really happening is the world is moving faster, and
things are getting bigger.
We have the capacity and computing power for large inputs,
but that doesn't mean efficiency
isn't a critical concern. The
reality is that you can, perhaps,
scan a billion items in a few seconds.
But if you have an algorithm that requires cubic complexity,
suddenly you're not talking about 10 raised to 9,
you're talking about 10 to 27. And
even current computers can't really
handle those kinds of numbers, so efficiency is a concern.
As the inputs get larger, it becomes more of a concern.
Good?
Therefore, we are concerned about the
efficiency of procedures for solving problems on a large scale
in this class.
We are concerned about the plausibility,
because - just as, you know, 1000
was a big number a few decades ago, and
now it's kind of a small number - it's quite
possible that by the time you guys professors
teaching this class at some universities are going to find that
trillion is going to be a small number.
We will talk about-- I don't know -
10 raised to 18 as something that we are
concerned about from the point of view of a common
input issue for an algorithm.
Therefore, gradual progression is important.
We want to be able to track how our algorithms are going to
do as the inputs get bigger and bigger.
You are going to learn a handful of different data structures.
We will call them classic data structures,
such as binary search trees, hash tables - that's
called dictionaries in Python - and data
structures - such as balanced binary search trees - that
are more efficient than just ordinary binary search trees.
These are all data structures
that were invented many decades ago.
But they have stood the test of time, and
they are still useful.
We are on our way to increasing these data structures in different ways
to make them more efficient for certain types of problems.
While you won't be doing much algorithm
design in this, you will be
doing some design and a lot of analysis. The
next class to this one, 6.046 Design Analysis
of Algorithms, is a class that you
should take if you like this one. And you can
do much more than design algorithms in 6.046.
But we will look at classical data structures
and classical algorithms for these data structures,
including things like sorting, matching, and so on.
One of the nice things about this class
is that you will actually do and implement these data structures and
In particular, each of the problem
sets in this category will have a theory
part of them, and a programming part of them.
So we hope that it will all tie together.
The types of things we are going to talk about in the lectures
and readings are going to be directly related
to the theoretical parts of the problem sets.
You need to program the algorithms we talk about
in a lecture, or add to them, run them.
Find out if they work well and also on large inputs or not.
So let me talk a little bit about the units
in this category and define the problem.
We hope that these problem sets
will be enjoyable for you.
Fun doesn't mean easy.
I mean, it was challenging and worthwhile, and at the end of it I
felt like you had learned something, and had
some fun along the way.
Good?
Therefore, content wisdom
- we have eight units in the class.
Each one of them, roughly speaking, has a
set of problems associated with it. The
first of these is what we call algorithmic thinking.
We will start today . As I mentioned,
we will take a special look
at the peak of the discovery.
As part of this, you're going to have a
problem setting this up to go out today as well.
You will find that in this problem, a group of
some of these algorithms I am talking about today
are encoded in Python and given to. And
there are a couple of them that are going to have the defect.
You will have to analyze the complexity of these algorithms.
Knowing which ones are correct and effective;
And write one of their guides.
Good?
Therefore, this is a kind of example of a problem problem. You
can expect that most of the problem identified
will follow this type of template.
Good.
Therefore, you will definitely feel better about this
by the end of the day.
Or a concrete meaning of this, because we will have to do
with a lecture and you should review the first problem set.
We will do that separately on sorting and trees.
Sort for you now, sort a set of numbers.
Imagine if you had trillions of digits
and you wanted to sort them.
What type of algorithm could be used for that?
Trees are a great data structure.
There are different types, the most common being biennial trees.
There are ways to do all sorts of things,
such as scheduling and sorting, using different types of trees,
including binary trees. We
have a problem simulating a logical network
using a certain type of sorting algorithm in the data
structure.
This would be the second problem identified.
And more quickly, we are going to have units on segmentation,
where we do things like genome comparison.
In the past, when we compared the human genome to the mouse genome,
we discovered they were very similar.
99% similar, which is kind of amazing.
But again, these things are so big that you
must be efficient in the comparison methods you
use.
You will find that if you do not get the complexity low
enough, you simply will not be able to complete it - the
program will not be able to finish running within the time
that your problem set does.
right?
Which is a bit of a problem.
Therefore, this is something to keep in mind while testing the code.
The truth is that you will get a lot of input to run your code.
You want to keep complexity in mind
as you code and think about the falsehood,
if you will, of your algorithm itself.
We will talk about the numbers.
There's a lot of time we've talked about these large numbers and
that 32 bits aren't enough.
Or 64 bits is not enough to represent these numbers.
These numbers have thousands of bits. A
good example of this is the encryption RSA,
which is used in SSL, for example.
When you go-- use HTTPS on websites,
RSA is used at the back end. It
usually works with prime numbers
that are thousands of bits long in RSA.
So how can you deal with that?
How does Python handle that?
How do you write algorithms that can
handle so-called infinite precision numbers?
Therefore, we have a unit on the numerical in the middle of the term that
talks about that.
Graphs are truly a fundamental data structure
in all of computer science. I had
heard of the famous Rubik's Cube
from.
006 a 2 B 2 B 2 Rubik's Cup.
What is the minimum number of moves
necessary to go from the given initial composition
to the final final composition, where all
faces are uniform in color?
This can be presented as a graph problem.
We will most likely use one of these terms.
In previous terms we did other things
like puzzle 15. And
even some of these are temporary.
We know for sure what the first problem group is like,
but the rest of them, at this moment, are temporary. And
to finish by taking the shortest route. To go back to the
past, we asked you
to write code using a particular algorithm that
finds the shortest route from Kaltish to MIT.
This time we might do things a little differently.
We were thinking maybe we could give you a Boston street map and you could find out
shortest routes to get where he was going,
or things like that.
We will try and make it fun.
Dynamic programming is an important algorithm design
technique used in many, many problems. It
can be used to do a variety of things, including
image compression.
How do you compress an image so that the number of pixels
decreases, but it still looks like the image you
started with, which was more than a pixel?
Good?
So that you can use dynamic programming for that.
Finally, advanced topics, complexity theory, research
and algorithms.
We hope that by now-- by this time in the course, it has been
sold on the algorithms.
And most, if not all, of you will
want to follow the carrier in the algorithms. We
will give you a sense of what's there.
We are just scratching the surface in this category, and
there are many, many more layers you can
take if you wish to continue learning about algorithms,
or to pursue a career in algorithms.
Good?
So this is the story of the class,
or a summary of the class.
I encourage you to go and spend a few minutes on the site.
In particular, please read the cooperation policy, and get a
sense of what is expected of you.
What are the rules in terms of conditions for performing problem sets?
Of course, grades are broken, as are
all the grading policies listed on the site.
Good.
So let's begin.
I want to talk about a specific problem.
And the discussion is about algorithms for a specific problem.
We chose this problem because it is very easy to understand.
They are, to some extent, obvious algorithms
that are not particularly effective at solving
this problem. And so
this is a kind of game problem.
But like many game problems, it is
very reminder-based in that it points to relevant issues
in the design of effective algorithms.
Therefore, we will start with a one-dimensional
version of what we call peak score. The
peak detector is something in a one-dimensional state.
It works on a range of numbers. And
I'm just putting
--symbols for each of these numbers here.
The numbers are positive, negative. We'll
just assume they're all positive;
it doesn't really matter.
The algorithms we described will work.
Thus we have this one-dimensional array
that has nine different positions.
And through me, numbers.
We want to find the peak.
Thus, we must know what we mean by peak.
Thus, in particular, as an example,
position 2 is the peak if, and only
if, b is greater than or equal to a, and b is greater than or equal
to c.
Therefore, it is really a very local property corresponding
to the peak.
In one dimension , it's a trivial case.
Look to your left.
Look at your rights.
If you are equal to or greater than both of the elements you
see on the left and right, you are peak.
Good?
In the case of edges, you only
need to look at one side.
Therefore, position 9 is the peak if i is greater than or equal to h.
So you just have to look to your left there,
because you're all the way on the right-hand side.
Good?
So that's all.
A statement of the problem, in one-dimensional
form, is to find the peak if it exists.
Good? That's
all there is to it.
I'm going to give you a clear algorithm.
Then we will see if we can improve it.
Good?
You can imagine that a clear algorithm is just
something that, you know, walks through a set.
But we need that as a starting point to build something
more advanced. Let's
assume we start from the left and all
we have is one pass, really.
So let's say we have 1, 2, then we
have more than 2 here corresponding
to the middle of this element n set.
Then we have n minus 1, and n.
What interests me in doing is not just
coming up with a clear algorithm,
but also specifically characterizing
what its complexity is in relation
to n, which is the number of inputs. indeed
? a
question?
Attendees: Why do you say if it exists
when the standards in [inaudible]
guarantees [inaudible]?
Professor: That's absolutely right. I was
going to get there.
Even if you look at the definition of peak,
then what I have here is greater than or equal to.
Good? And so
this—this is a great question that has been asked.
Why is there an "if it exists" in this problem?
Now, in the case where I have greater than or equal to,
then - this is the homework question for you,
the rest is up to you - argue that any array will always
have a peak.
Good?
Now, if you don't have greater than or equal to,
and you do have greater than, then can you make this argument?
No, you can't.
right? That's a
very big question.
In this case it is only a question -
you want to modify this problem
statement to find the peak.
But if I have a different definition of peak - that's
part of algorithmic thinking.
You want to be able to create algorithms that are generic,
so if the problem defines changes for you, you
still have a starting point to go attacking the
second version of the problem.
Good?
So that you can rule this out in the case
of greater than or equal to the definition.
And "if it exists," because a peak always exists.
But you might want to argue that whenever
you want to demonstrate the validity of your algorithm.
And if you actually have a different definition,
well you will have to create an algorithm that tells you
for sure that the peak does not exist, or finds a
peak if it does exist.
Good?
Therefore, this is really the general case.
Many times you may be asked to do something, and
you cannot actually give an answer to the question,
or find something that satisfies all the required constraints.
In this case, you want to be able to throw out your hand
and say, you know what? I have
searched for a long and difficult time. I have
researched thoroughly.
Here is my argument: I have searched thoroughly, and I
could not find it.
right?
If you do that, you get your job.
Otherwise, there is always the case that you did
not do that research hard enough.
So it's nice that they have this argument.
Good?
great. Thank you for the question.
Don't hesitate to boycott.
Raise your hand, I'm watching, guys, and
I'm happy to answer questions anytime.
So let's talk about a clear algorithm. A
straightforward algorithm is something
that starts from the left and just goes through. You
might have something that looks like this.
Good?
By this I mean that the numbers increase
as they start from the left, peak somewhere
in the middle, and then things start to go down.
right?
Even in this case, you know, this could be the peak. You
may also have a situation where
the peak is all the way to the right,
you started from the left.
And it is 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, literally
in terms of numbers.
As you go to look at n elements going all the way
to the right in the system to find the peak.
Even in the middle, you were
looking at n more than 2 elements.
If the right is in the middle. And
the complexity, the worst case complexity
- what we call theta n. And
it's theta n, because in the worst-case scenario, you
might have to look at all.
This is the case where you started from the left and you had to
go all the way to the right.
Now remember, theta n is basically something and
this says of order n.
Therefore, it offers you both the lowest binding and the highest limit.
big [? [O?] of n is only the upper limit.
What we are saying here, we are
saying this algorithm that starts from the left
is, essentially, in the worst case, something that requires
Good?
And you know this constant can be 1.
Can things definitely be set this way?
Or if you have a different type of algorithm,
perhaps you could work on a constant.
But the bottom line is, we are only concerned, at this moment, with the
volatile complexity. The
fluctuating complexity of this algorithm is linear.
Good? Is
this reasonable?
Good.
Until someone helps me do a better job.
How can we do better?
How can we reduce the fluctuating complexity
of a one-dimensional peak finder?
Anyone want to take a stab at that? indeed
Back there.
Attendance: A sub-search pair.
You looked at the middle, and whichever side was
higher—whichever side was higher—then cut that in half,
because you know there's a peak.
Professor: On--
on the right side-- there are more
on the right side-- then you just
look at that, because you know your peak is somewhere
there. And the
Professor: Excellent!
excellent!
That's absolutely true.
Therefore, you can—you can do something different, which
is basically trying to unpack and dismantle this problem.
Using the gap and conquer strategy, repeatedly
breaking this single-dimensional array into smaller arrays.
And trying to get this complicated down. indeed
Attendees: Are we assuming there is only one peak?
Professor: No, we are not.
Attendees: Agreed.
Professor: It finds its peak if it exists.
In this case, it is, "finding the peak,"
because of the definition.
We don't really need this as has been discussed.
Good?
Good.
Therefore—so that
was a great answer, and—you know this category
after a while goes to get boring.
right?
Every category gets boring.
So we are, you know, trying to break the monotony here a little.
And so—then the other thing we realized
was that these seats you were sitting on—this
is the classroom—but the seats you're sitting on
are kind of hard.
right?
So what Eric and I have decided is that we
will help you with men, especially those who are
- who are and interact with us. And
we have these -
[laughter] - the main ones
As you know, this is a 2 by 2 Rubik's Cube here.
Since you answered the first question, you can get a pillow.
This is kind of like a Frisbee, but not really.
Therefore--
[laughs] I'm
not sure - I'm not sure I'm going to get it for you.
But the other thing I want to say is
this is not baseball.
right?
Where I was just grabbing the ball as it came by.
This means to him, my friend in the red shirt. This is where you
go. Oh, it's so bad
Good.
It's soft.
So, you know, it won't hurt you if it hits you.
[Laughter]
Okay.
So we got a set of these. And
raise your hands, you know, going to
ask—there to be —I think—there are
some trivial questions that we will ask just to
make sure you are awake.
Therefore, the answer to that is: you don't get a pillow.
But an answer like - What's your name?
Attendees: Chase.
Professor: Chase.
An answer like Chase just gave is -
that's a good answer to an unimportant question.
To get you a pillow.
Good?
Absolutely, great.
Therefore, let's introduce the Chase algorithm here.
I'm going to write that out for the 1D version.
Therefore, what we have here is a recurrent algorithm.
Therefore, the image you want to keep in your head
is this image that I put there.
This is the split and conquer algorithm.
You are going to see this more and more - this model -
over and over again in 6.006.
We are considering more than 2 positions.
We are going to look to the left, and
we are going to look to the right.
We are going to do that in sequence.
Therefore,
if more than 2 is less than more than 2 minus 1, then
look only at the left half.
1 to n greater than 2 minus 1 to find the peak - for the peak.
Good?
This is the first step.
And you know that I can put it on the right side
or the left side, it doesn't really matter.
I chose to do the left hand on the first side, the left half.
So what I did was, through that step,
if you actually have that condition - more than 2
less than 2 minus 1 - then you can move to the left
and you're working on one half of the problem.
But if that is not the case, then if n over-- n more than 2
less than n over-- n by 2 plus 1,
then we only look at n more than 2 plus 1 to n for the peak.
Therefore, I didn't bother writing out all the words.
They are exactly the same as the left side. I
was just taking a look at the right side.
Otherwise, if none of these conditions apply to the fire, you would have already done it
.
Good?
This is actually the best case in terms of finishing early,
at least in this recursive step.
Because now more than n 2 positions is the peak.
Because what I found is that n is greater than 2 positions
greater than or equal to either of its adjacent positions, and
that is exactly the definition of a peak. So, that's the
end of it.
Good?
So all of this is good.
You want to write an argument that this algorithm is correct. And
I'm not going to bother with that.
I'm just waving my hand a bit, and you're all shot,
so we're done with that.
But the point you will see in your problem set is a
precise argument for a more complex algorithm, a 2D
version of this.
This should be your model for going to write proof,
or an argument, a formal argument,
that a particular algorithm is correct. To
do what she claims to do.
In this case, it's two, three lines of precise reasoning
that basically say, given the definition of peak,
that this is going to be finding a peak in a set
that you are given.
Good?
Therefore, we all believe that this algorithm is correct.
Let's now talk about the complexity of this algorithm.
Because every point of this algorithm is
because we did not do it like this, theta
n complexity corresponds to a clear algorithm.
Therefore, you want to do better.
So what I would like to ask is if one of you could
give me a recurrence relation of this type, you know, T of n
equals blah, blah, blah.
This is consistent with this recursive algorithm,
this splitting and conquering algorithm.
Then, using that, I would like to arrive at the actual complexity
in terms of what theta of complexity corresponds. indeed
Going back there?
Attendees: So the worst- case scenario if T of n
will be some fixed amount of time -
Professor: Yes.
Attendees: --it takes to investigate whether a given
item [inaudible], plus -
[cough]
--T of n more than 2?
Professor: Great.
Absolutely true.
That's absolutely true.
So if you look at this algorithm and say,
from a calculation point of view, can I
write the equation corresponding to the implementation
of this algorithm?
It states that T of n is the work that this algorithm works on - as
inputs of size n.
Good?
Then I can write this equation.
This theta 1 corresponds to the two comparisons you
were looking at - and possibly the two comparisons you
do - looking at the left-hand side and the
right-hand side.
Therefore, 's--2' is a constant, so that's why we put theta 1.
Okay?
So you can get a pillow, too.
Beware of men.
Stop!
Oh, actually it wasn't that bad.
good. Fares left
, Eric.
Virus left.
Even if you take this and start expanding it,
eventually you're going to reach the base
case, which is T of 1 is theta 1.
Right?
Because you have only one element in the array for that group,
it's just going to go back to that peak.
So if you do that, and you can expand every way out,
then you can write T of n equals theta 1 plus theta 1.
And you are going to do that log to base 2 of n times.
Adding all of this together gives you a
theta log 2 complexity of n.
right?
So far, compare this with that.
There is indeed a big difference.
There is a significant difference.
If you encode this algorithm in Python -
and I did - both are 1D version algorithms -
and if you run it on n and it's running 10 million or so,
then this algorithm takes 13 seconds.
Good?
The-- Theta 10 algorithm takes 13 seconds.
This takes 0.001 seconds.
Good?
Big difference.
Therefore, there is a big difference between theta n and theta log
It is literally the difference between 2 raised to n, n. It makes
sense to try and reduce complexity
as you see, especially if you are
talking about large inputs.
Good?
You will see this more clearly as we
move to a 2D version of this problem.
Good?
Therefore, you really can't do better for 1D.
And 1D is an obvious problem.
It gets a little more interesting -
the problems get a little - oops,
the algorithms get a little more sophisticated
when we look at the 2D version of the peak score.
So let's talk about the 2D version.
You can even imagine in the 2D version that
you have a matrix, or a two-dimensional matrix. We
will say this thing contains rows and columns M.
Now we need to determine what the peak is.
And it's a hill.
It is a clear definition of peak.
Even if you have it here, C, B, D, E.
Then, as you can guess, it is the peak of 2D if, and only if,
greater than or equal to b; Greater than or equal to d, c
e.
Good? It
's even a small hill there.
Good?
And again I have used greater than or equal to here,
so that it is similar to 1D in this case
that you will always find a peak in any 2D matrix.
Now again I will give you a clear algorithm, and we will
call it the Greedy Ascent Algorithm. The
greedy ascent algorithm basically chooses the direction
and, you know, tries to follow that direction in the system
to find the peak.
For example, if you had this particular
--matrix; 14, 13, 12, 15, 9, 11, 17--
Then what might happen is if you start at some arbitrary
middle - so the greedy ascent algorithm
has to make choices about where to start.
Just as we have had different cases here,
you have to make a choice about where to start. You
may want to start in the middle,
or you may want to work your way left first.
Or you're going all the way - you were just continuing left,
we're continuing in the right direction.
If you hit an edge, you go down.
Therefore, some options were made, such as what the default traversal
directions are.
So if I tell you you want to start with 12,
you're going to look for something to the left.
And if it's bigger than that, I'm going to follow that trend.
If it is not so, if it is less, then you are
going to go in the other direction, in this case,
for example.
So in this case you will go to 12, 13, 14, 15, 16, 17, 19,
and 20.
And you find—you'd find this peak.
Now I haven't given you specific details
of the greedy climb algorithm.
But I think if you look at the worst-case scenario
here, with respect to a particular matrix, to
any particular starting point,
and to any particular strategy - in terms of choosing left first,
versus right first, or down first versus first - you
would have a situation where - just
like we had in the 1D case - you might end up
touching a large portion of the elements in this 2D array.
Good?
So in this case, we ended up, you know,
touching on a handful of different elements.
It is quite possible that it could eventually end up touching -
starting from the middle point - it could reach touching half of the
elements, and in some cases, touching all of the elements.
Even if you do the worst case analysis of this algorithm - a
particular algorithm with certain options in terms of conditions
of the starting point and search direction - the
greedy ascending algorithm will have theta nm complexity.
Good?
In the case where n equals m, or m equals n,
you have theta n squared complexity.
Good?
I'm not going to spend too much time on this,
because I want to talk to you about splitting and
conquering versions of this 2D peak algorithm.
But we hope you are with all due respect
to what the worst case of complexity is.
Good?
People buy that? indeed.
The question is there again.
Attendees: Can you - can you get closer?
Or could you actually get to pass a certain number of times?
Professor: So there are specific greedy ascent algorithms, and
specific matrices where, if I give you the
algorithm code, I give you a specific matrix,
which can make you work by touching all these elements.
This is correct.
Therefore, we are talking about the worst-case scenario. You were being
very paranoid when you were
talking about the worst-case scenario . And
so I'm—the hand is waving a bit here, just
because I haven't given you details
of the algorithm yet.
right?
This is really a set of algorithms,
because I haven't given you code,
I haven't told you where it starts,
and which direction it goes.
But go, do that, fix it, and I'll be the one
trying to find the worst-case scenario.
Suddenly it is very easy to get theta n
m in terms of having some constant multiplied by n times m.
But you can definitely get that constant
being very close to 1.
Okay?
If not 1, then
okay.
So let's talk about divide and conquer.
Let's say I did something
like this, where I just tried to jam the binary search
algorithm in the 2D version.
Good?
So what I'm going to do is -- I'm
going to choose the middle column, j equals m greater than 2.
And I'm going to find the 1D peak using
whatever algorithm I want. And
I'm probably going to end up using a more efficient algorithm, the
binary search version that went all the way
to the left of the board there.
Let's say I find the dual peak in (T, Y).
Because I chose a column, I'm just finding the 1D peak.
This is j equals m greater than 2.
This is i.
Now I use (i, j).
Specifically, row i as a starting point
- find the 1D peak on row i. As
I stand here, I am truly happy.
Good?
Because I say, a resounding success.
I chose the middle column, I found the 1D peak, and
this is the complexity of m theta for finding the 1D peak as we argued.
One side—theta m—
attendance: record n.
Professor: Oh, I'm sorry.
You are right. The
complexity register is n, that's what this was.
So I have it here. indeed.
Recording complexity n.
Thanks, Eric.
Then after I do that, I can find the 1D peak on row T.
In this case, the row will be m wide,
so the logarithm will be m complexity.
If n equals m, then I have a double, because of, the steps, because of, log, n,
and I did.
Good? Did
I?
no.
Can someone tell me why I didn't?
precisely?
Yes.
Attention: Because when you do the second part
to find the peak in the first row,
that column may not be the peak - it may no longer
be a peak on the column.
Professor: That's exactly right.
Therefore, this algorithm is incorrect.
Good? It doesn't
work.
It is effective, but incorrect.
Good?
It's -- you want it to be true.
You know, being corrected and ineffective
is definitely better than being ineffective - I'm sorry.
Being incorrect and ineffective.
Therefore, this is an efficient algorithm,
in the sense that it will only take a record of time,
but it does not work.
And I'll give you a simple example
here where it doesn't work.
The problem is--
--a 2D peak--
--may not exist-
--on row i.
And here's an example of that.
Actually this is-- This is exactly the example of that.
Let's say that I started with this row.
Since it's-- I'm starting with the middle row,
and I could start with this one or that one.
Let's say I started with that one.
I end up finding a peak.
And if this were 10 up here, I'd choose 12 as a peak.
And it's quite possible that I return 12 as a peak.
Even though 19 is bigger, because 12
is a peak given 10 and 11 up here.
And then when I choose this particular row,
and I find a peak on this row, it would be 14.
That is a 1D peak on this row.
But 14 is not a 2D peak.
OK?
So this particular example, 14 would return 14.
And 14 is not a 2D peak.
All right?
You can collect your cushion after the class.
So not so good.
Look like an efficient algorithm, but it doesn't work.
All right?
So how can we get to something that actually works?
So the last algorithm that I'm going to show you--
And you'll see four different algorithms in your problem
set--
--that you'll have to analyze the complexity for and decide
if they're efficient, and if they're correct.
But here's a-- a recursive version
that is better than, in terms of complexity,
than the Greedy Ascent algorithm.
And this one works.
So what I'm going to do is pick a middle column.
j equals m over 2 as before.
I'm going to find the global maximum on column j.
And that's going to be at (i, j).
I'm going to compare (i comma j minus 1), (i comma j),
and (i,j plus 1).
Which means that once I've found the maximum in this row,
all I'm going to look to the left and the right,
and compare.
I'm going to pick the left columns.
If (i comma j minus 1) is greater than (i comma j)--
and similarly for the right.
And if in fact I-- either of these two conditions
don't fire, and what I have is (i comma j)
is greater than or equal to (i comma j minus 1)
and (i comma j plus 1), then I'm done.
Just like I had for the 1D version.
If (i comma j) is greater than or equal to (i comma
j minus 1), and (i comma j plus 1), that implies (i, j)
is a 2D peak.
OK?
And the reason that is the case, is
because (i comma j) was the maximum element in that column.
So you know that you've compared it
to all of the adjacent elements, looking up and looking down,
that's the maximum element.
Now you've look at the left and the right,
and in fact it's greater than or equal to the elements
on the left and the right.
And so therefore it's a 2D peak.
OK?
So in this case, when you pick the left or the right columns--
you'll pick one of them-- you're going
to solve the new problem with half the number of columns.
All right?
And again, you have to go through an analysis,
or an argument, to make sure that this algorithm is correct.
But its intuitively correct, simply because it matches
the 1D version much more closely.
And you also have your condition where you break away right
here, where you have a 2D peak, just like the 1D version.
And what you've done is break this matrix up
into half the size.
And that's essentially why this algorithm works.
When you have a single column--
--find the global maximum and you're done.
All right?
So that's the base case.
So let me end with just writing out
what the recurrence relationship for the complexity of this
is, and argue what the overall complexity of this algorithm
is.
And then I'll give you the bad news.
All right.
So overall what you have is, you have something like T of (n, m)
equals T of (n, m over 2) plus theta n.
Why is that?
Well n is the number of rows, m is the number of columns.
In one case you'll be breaking things down
into half the number of columns, which is m over 2.
And in order to find the global maximum,
you'll be doing theta n work, because you're
finding the global maximum.
Right?
You just have to scan it-- this--
That's the way-- That's what it's going to take.
And so if you do that, and you go run it through--
and you know that T of (n, 1) is theta n-- which
is this last part over here-- that's your base case.
You get T of (n, m) is theta of n added to theta of n,
log of m times-- log 2 of m times.
Which is theta of n-- log 2 of m.
All right?
So you're not done with peak finding.
What you'll see is at four algorithms coded in Python--
I'm not going to give away what those algorithms are,
but you'll have to recognize them.
You will have seen versions of those algorithms
already in lecture.
And your job is going to be to analyze the algorithms, as I
said before, prove that one of them is correct,
and find counter-examples for the ones that aren't correct.
The course staff will stick around
here to answer questions-- logistical questions--
or questions about the lecture.
And I owe that gentleman a cushion.